بعد ساعات من طرد مثيري الشغب الأخير
من مبنى الكابيتول بينما
كان لا يزال هناك زجاج على الأرضيات والدم
على السلالم حاول المؤتمر العودة
إلى
مجال الديمقراطية
[الموسيقى]
، فلنعد إلى العمل أجروا
انتخابات رئاسية للتصديق
اجتمعنا مجددًا في تلك الليلة ، كانت هناك
فرصة للقيادة من كيفن
مكارثي ، فرصة له
للوقوف والقول أن الوقت قد حان لكي ندرك
أن الانتخابات قد انتهت
، وعلينا أن نتحد معًا وأن
أتعافى.  في هذه القاعة اليوم عندما
جلست على الأرض واستمعت إلى
ملاحظاته ، بدأوا على هذا النحو ولكن
بعد ذلك أصبح من الواضح أنه كان يحث على
استمرار الاعتراض على
الأصوات الانتخابية التي لا أستطيع أن
أفهم أننا نسمع مخاوف صحيحة
بشأن نزاهة الانتخابات من قبل
نهاية الليلة ، صوت ثلثا الجمهوريين في
مجلس النواب بما
في ذلك القيادة الجمهورية الحالية على
عدم التصديق على حالة أريزونا أنا
أعترض على المنتخب  التصويت الشفوي وعدم
التصديق على كومنولث بنسلفانيا ،
هل تعتقد أن كيفن مكارثي وستيف سكاليس
وإليز ستيفانيك قد صوتوا جميعًا
لعدم عد الناخبين بعد إراقة
الدماء بعد هذا الهجوم ،
هل تعتقد أنهم يعتقدون بالفعل أن
هذا السبب الذي اتخذوه  ليس
بكلمة واحدة ، لا أعتقد أنهم يصدقون
أيًا منها ،
لكن أعتقد أنه يمكنك إقناع نفسك
إذا كنت مصممًا على ذلك ،
سألعب اللعبة لفترة أطول قليلاً
حتى أكون هنا لأقود إلى  اتجاه جديد
أو سألعب اللعبة لأنني لا
أملك القوة والتأثير
لتغيير السفينة التي تعرفها عندما
تفكر في البطولات في الرحلة 93 على 911 ،
فأنت تعلم أن كل هؤلاء الركاب
يقفون مسرعون في قمرة القيادة وينقذون  كان على
العاصمة
أن يتعاطى المخدرات أو أي من هؤلاء الآخرين
بمفردهم يشحنون قمرة القيادة ، فمن المحتمل أن يكون لدينا
عاصمة أعيد بناؤها اليوم
والعديد من الضحايا ، لكنهم قرروا
جميعًا القيام بذلك معًا وعندما يكون لديك
عدد قليل من الأشخاص يتحدثون علانية ، فلا شك في
ذلك  لن يغير مسار السفينة
لدى الجميع ولا
سيما قادة الحزب